spice k2 bliss blaze what's the deal
with synthetic marijuana well to start
with it's not really marijuana at all
packages may refer to natural
ingredients but these chemicals are made
in a lab and sprayed onto herbes that
you smoke it's more accurate to call
them synthetic cannabinoids drugs that
affect the same part of the brain as
natural compounds found in marijuana the
thing is these synthetics affect the
brain much more strongly than weed and
when they break down inside the body
their components continue to affect you
as well the US government has outlawed
some formulas but the manufacturers
switched fuel gradients around to
temporarily get around the laws so how
do you know what you're getting policy
burst and I have a bottle in the mall